[Music]
hey guys see that little pair of
eyeballs sticking out from underneath
those reindeer pelts
that's my four-year-old son nathan
and today
we're in the alaskan bush in the dead of
winter and we're doing another extreme
survival camping video
we're gonna see if we can't survive
out here in the winter
with no tent
no heaters
no sleeping bags
you ready nathan
yeah you are
but first we've got to get off the
beaten path and to do that
is going to take a lot of brute strength
and leg work
well it's 10 30 in the morning and we
just saw the sun rise
we're gonna need every ounce of
sunlight we can
to get our shelter built
and get enough firewood
for the night
it's gonna be cold
real cold
just saw some
wolf tracks
and wolf scat
hopefully that won't be an issue
but if it is
we're prepared
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right i think this is where we're
gonna make our campsite right here
let's get cracking we need to build a
shelter and a fire quickly when you're
moving around and snowshoeing and
swinging an axe you build up a sweat and
that is not good you cannot get sweaty
so you're stripping off layers when
you're too hot
putting layers on when you're too cold
and only for a few minutes the whole day
will be just right
let's see what's down here
ugh
oh
[Music]
you gotta stay hydrated
and that means keeping liquid water
handy all this water around me is no
good unless it's wet
so keep a bottle of water inside your
snow pants so it stays warm
there we go
i take these i'm gonna wrap you up a
little bit one
reindeer back
and then
another one
there you go nate you feeling warmer
good
cool though
[Music]
uh
[Music]
we're done
well i'm almost done with my shelter
but it looks like my camping buddy's
taking a little nap
this is a blast match it's basically
ferrous rod
steel
i'm having a little trouble starting my
fire so i'm gonna go old school
building a fire in the cold is a lot
like building a fire in the rain
the wood is so cold and caked with ice
that you need to defrost it before it'll
light
so you kind of need to pile it up high
and fan it frequently
nathan woke up
and we need to get this boy
some food
oh
that looks good
all right
get you off the ground
does that feel better your hands feel
better nathan
here try this again it's probably cool
[Music]
moths yeah yep there's moths but only in
the summer here you go you got buddy
you want your little rolling state juice
i need at least one luxury per camping
trip
let's do this
campfire easy mac
youtube you're doing good as a mom i did
as good as mom yeah thank you
you enjoying your mac and cheese
yeah all right get our beds made and
tonight
we're gonna be sleeping on reindeer
hides
here i'm gonna throw it over here
look what we got for dessert
chocolates
for those of you out there with young
daughters you will recognize these
pillows as sven the reindeer from the
cartoon frozen which i thought would be
really appropriate since we're sleeping
on reindeer hides in the middle of
winter
we got one sleeping bag and that's for
nathan
taking a four-year-old out negative
temperatures is no joke so
i have a negative 30
mummy bag here this is a very expensive
bag we should be able to keep you warm
in this nate oh
look at my gloves
those are my my gloves i took them off
and they got frozen anyone who's done a
lot of winter camping has also burned up
a lot of gloves and boots and socks so
we're just gonna hang these right here
and hopefully they will not catch fire
these are really really frozen aren't
they
okay it's not loaded but it's
really careful okay wow that's how you
like that
and then you like that and that puts a
bullet in it daytime we'll
we'll uh
no
it's only six o'clock so
we got a little time here just to sit by
the fire and kind of dry off
and then we're gonna go to sleep and
hopefully
we'll stay warm all right we got all of
our firewood stacked up ready for
tonight and it's a little bit of a trick
you want to stack your wood around the
fire so that it dries out and thaws out
before it's time to put it on the fire
but of course you don't want it too
close because if your wood pile catches
fire you could wake up to a giant
bonfire in your face well the fire and
the shelter are doing a great job nice
and warm in front a little chilly on the
back but not bad it'll probably get down
to the negative numbers tonight
and i think we'll be just fine as long
as we can keep this fire stoked you
don't want to sleep in your sleeping bag
yeah just keep
hiding you wanna just sleep under the
caribou hide
all right
that's crazy
well it's about 10 p.m and nathan
is snoring away
look at him
he's just snug as a bug in a rug between
two caribou hides
i'm doing pretty good i'm staying warm
my back's a little cold but it's not a
big deal
but mostly i'm just on the lumpiest
piece of ground there's this weird bump
and it's kind of hard to find a good
comfortable position well it's 1 30 in
the morning and uh
i've discovered we have a little bit of
a fuel problem but you can see the two
logs i was using as a heat reflector the
fire cut through them and i folded them
in on each other those are pretty chunky
logs so those should last a while but
other than that i've got two big logs
and half a dozen small logs and that's
it
all of that wood i cut it's gone i mean
that was like
four or five spruce trees worth well
good morning it's a little before 7am
and i still have some fire here
so hopefully we can make the fuel last a
little bit longer cook some breakfast
maybe just maybe last us to sun up
around uh two hours ago nathan woke up
and asked me to put him in the sleeping
bag but other than that he slept
underneath the reindeer hide the whole
night i'm just gonna kind of quietly
make some breakfast and so when he wakes
up here in an hour or so i have
something warm to eat
yeah there you go the eggs froze solid
that's cold weather camping for you
we got the eggs thawing out down there
so hopefully it'll have eggs here soon
well i finished breakfast and nathan
didn't stir it all and he's sleeping in
and that's great
but while i still have some fuel i think
i might start cooking lunch
i'm going to make some beef stew just
have that ready i brought some beef
stock with me you can see it's partially
frozen which is pretty impressive
considering how much salt is in there
all right
time to add the seasonings got a little
garlic there
let's see
oh
got some frozen basil got some bay
leaves some oregano
ew
oh yeah that looks and smells perfect
well it's nine o'clock and i've got two
surprises one nathan's still asleep
and two
i still have some wood left over oh
we're gonna make it to sunrise
but uh we're gonna let nathan sleep for
just a little bit more here then i'm
gonna wake him up we gotta tell you what
i really enjoy sleeping on those
reindeer hides they are an amazing
insulator in my opinion the worst part
of winter camping is getting out of a
warm sleeping bag and putting on cold
boots and clothes so just laid his boots
and hung up his jackets
right there by the fire so hopefully
they'll be toasty warm when he gets up
nathan
nathan buddy
buddy wake
up you slept in a lot
nathan do you want some hot chocolate
and breakfast
here's some bacon
mmm
bacon
i know they don't teach kids cursive in
school anymore
but gosh darn it my kids are learning
he's practicing his letters over there
well we're packing up and this trip is
coming to a close hopefully you guys
enjoyed watching this video as much as
we enjoyed filming it if you guys like
this sort of thing don't forget to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
saturday morning and we have tons of
camping and survival videos thanks for
watching and don't forget to click
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]